[Aplausos]
[Música]
os garantizo que una de las cosas que
más te sorprenden cuando llegas a japón
y la verdad son muchas las cosas que te
sorprenden son la seguridad y la
confianza que se siente
[Música]
veréis japón es uno de los pocos países
del mundo donde te puedes dejar un
iphone 10 en una cafetería por ejemplo y
volver al día siguiente tranquilamente a
por él porque amigos casi con total
seguridad tu iphone 10 nuevecito recién
estrenado va a estar allí esperándote
[Música]
y no no estoy exagerando por supuesto
puedes tener mala suerte pero no es lo
habitual además amigos japón es un país
precioso con rincones increíbles donde
todo parece estar donde tiene que estar
por mi parte os lo recomiendo como
destino japón nunca defrauda pero como
sabéis este no es un canal de viajes ni
este un vídeo patrocinado por el
ministerio de turismo del japón así que
al grano
[Música]
recientemente amigos hemos conocido que
el emperador akihito ha decidido aplicar
japón anuncia que el emperador akihito
abdicará en abril de 2019
pues bien atentos al dato este emperador
llegó al trono hace casi 30 años en 1989
justo el año en que comenzó la crisis
japonesa
no cuidado en japón el emperador no
tiene ningún poder así que aquí no ha
sido responsable pero no me digáis que
no es coincidencia y mala suerte
prácticamente podemos decir que fue
llegar a este emperador y 30 años de
estancamiento pues bien en este vídeo
vamos a ver qué pasó qué causó esta gran
crisis y por qué el modelo alemán ha
conseguido batir al modelo japonés pero
antes amigos veamos un poquito de
historia
[Música]
los milagros existen
[Aplausos]
japón y alemania son dos países muy
interesantes con muchas coincidencias y
también con muchas diferencias tras la
segunda guerra mundial los dos países
estaban literalmente en ruinas habían
perdido no solo sus infraestructuras
sino prácticamente también a toda una
generación
sin embargo entre los años 50 y los años
70 los dos países vivieron un despegue
tan importante que en esas dos décadas
no sólo consiguieron recuperarse sino
que lograron convertirse en dos de las
mayores economías del mundo y en dos de
los países más ricos
de hecho aunque hoy nos pueda parecer
increíble durante años se llegó a
especular con que japón podría llegar a
superar a los mismísimos eeuu como la
mayor economía del mundo cómo han
cambiado las cosas
el caso es que entre 1955 y 1973 japón
crece una media anual del 9% y del año
73 al 90 por encima del 4% vamos que son
unos datos de matrícula y alemania- ojo
no se quedó atrás tuvo crecimientos
medios del 7% anual durante casi 30 años
las dos locomotoras amigos estaban a
pleno rendimiento las fábricas de los
dos países trabajaban a destajo el paro
no existía y tanto alemanes como
japoneses ahorraban a invertían su
dinero por todo el mundo de repente las
empresas japonesas y alemanas comenzaron
a cobrar fama y a ser conocidas
mundialmente
[Aplausos]
algo que tiene mucho mérito
especialmente en el caso de japón un
país que por así decirlo vive bajo el
constante acoso de la naturaleza
además de ser un país muy montañoso
japón sufre todo tipo de desastres
naturales terremotos ciclones maremotos
tsunamis etcétera etcétera
de hecho amigos como anécdota os contaré
que en la primera noche que pasé en
tokio experimenté un terremoto de grado
53 que aunque bueno no es muy grande si
te hace experimentar lo que pueden
suponer por cierto en próximos vídeos
aquí en visual político os contaremos
con detalle cómo se produjeron estos dos
milagros económicos
[Música]
el caso es que en 1989 todo este
despegue económico se frenó y llegó a su
fin y dio paso a lo que ya se conoce
como el gran estancamiento japonés japón
se hunde en la tormenta perfecta de
estancamiento burbuja y deuda lo sé
estoy convencido de que todo esto no es
nuevo para vosotros al fin y al cabo no
es extraño que cada vez que se hable
deja por termine haciendo presencia
antes o después la palabra crisis
[Música]
sí desde que tengo uso de memoria japón
ha sido algo así como el país de la
crisis eterna el país que tiene un año
bueno y tres malos de hecho hoy podemos
decir claramente que alemania ha sido
por así decirlo la gran vencedora en esa
carrera por el crecimiento que los dos
países mantuvieron durante décadas
[Música]
y hoy alemania que ojo también ha pasado
malos momentos en las últimas décadas es
más rica tiene unas cuentas públicas
mucho más saneadas es más competitiva a
nivel internacional y encima a los
alemanes tienen salarios más altos
fijaos para hacernos una idea de cuál es
la situación de japón creo que nos basta
con dos datos muy pero que muy
relevantes primero en japón los salarios
reales esto es teniendo en cuenta la
inflación son hoy inferiores ojo a los
salarios que los japoneses tenían en
1990 hace 30 años y segundo la deuda
pública del gobierno japonés es la más
alta del mundo supone el 250 por ciento
del pib y el 250 por ciento lo habéis
escuchado bien
[Música]
así que amigos creo que aquí la pregunta
que muchos os estáis haciendo es qué
diantres ocurrió que ha hecho que el
modelo alemán sea mucho mejor que el
modelo japonés pues evidentemente
razones hay muchas pero creemos que tres
de ellas son con diferencia las más
importantes veamos las
[Música]
un modelo problemático
en primer lugar podemos decir que una
gran diferencia entre el desarrollo de
japón y el de alemania el país del sol
naciente amigos apostó por proteger a
grandes conglomerados industriales los
kir ets y los kir etsu son por así
decirlo una especie de holding que hacen
prácticamente de todo es decir que
tienen empresas que se dedican a todo
tipo de cosas coches aviones neumáticos
pasta de dientes
todo fabricado por un mismo holding
cuyas empresas se apoyan entre sí se
compran y venden productos entre ellas e
incluso llegaron a tener sus propios
bancos para financiarse
[Música]
el problema de todo esto es que estos
grandes conglomerados tendían a ser muy
burocráticos y poco flexibles
por así decirlo en ellos tomar
decisiones era un proceso difícil y muy
lento
[Música]
pero para compensar todas estas
desventajas ahí estaba el gobierno
japonés que no dudó en darles todo tipo
de ventajas y privilegios por ejemplo
los financiaba generosamente a tipos
anormalmente bajos a través de programas
específicos de el banco central de japón
sin embargo amigos los resultados al
final no fueron nada pero que nada
buenos
fijaos estos grandes grupos se hicieron
muy influyentes en la política del país
escondían muchos problemas porque claro
cuando a una empresa de estos
conglomerados le iba mal era muy fácil
que contagiará al resto estaban muy
endeudadas y por si fuese poco limitaban
la competencia
claro cómo competir contra semejantes
grupos que además están protegidos por
el gobierno y que cuentan con todo tipo
de privilegios suena difícil verdad en
alemania en cambio la apuesta política
fue completamente diferente y se centró
en crear un mercado muy competitivo con
muchas pequeñas y medianas empresas
ojo hay grandes grupos industriales por
supuesto y eso es algo bueno siempre y
cuando no dependan del gobierno ni
reciban privilegios que impidan la
competencia el resultado amigos es que
los grandes grupos japoneses han tenido
muchos pero que muchos problemas y la
mayoría de ellos han desaparecido o
quebrado en algún momento pero aquí no
acaba todo
la política del descuento
durante años los políticos japoneses
pensaron que para exportar más eso de
devaluar de vez en cuando la moneda pues
que no era algo nada malo sin embargo en
1985 empezaron los problemas de verdad
atentos
como consecuencia de todas estas guerras
de divisas eeuu tenía un déficit
exterior bastante grande
y como a los políticos de washington de
entonces como los de ahora esto no les
hacía ninguna gracia forzaron los
llamados acuerdos de plaza un acuerdo
entre eeuu japón alemania francia y
reino unido- para depreciar el dólar con
el objetivo de reducir este déficit
comercial
pues bien como os podéis imaginar esto
supuso todo un mazazo para la industria
japonesa que estaba acostumbrada a
competir con alguna que otra ayuda y que
pensáis que hizo el gobierno puedes
decirles hay tranquilos aquí estoy yo
para salvaros así que dicho y hecho
el gobierno japonés hundió los tipos de
interés y empezó a impulsar el crédito
como si no hubiese mañana
[Música]
el resultado una enorme espiral de deuda
bancos que repartían dinero a lo loco y
una descomunal burbuja en el mercado
inmobiliario y en los mercados
financieros y que creéis que pasó pues
que en 1990 todo ese castillo de naipes
comenzó a venirse abajo
esto no es parte
en la alemania en cambio también lo
hemos visto aquí en visual político el
gobierno ha puesto por mantener un marco
fuerte lo que por un lado obligaba a las
empresas a competir en productividad e
innovación pero por otro les permitía
comprar tecnología y máquinas
extranjeras con mejores condiciones pero
amigos aún existe una tercera diferencia
determinante atentos
encerrados en sí mismos
y japón es el país más envejecido del
mundo algo más del 25 por ciento de su
población es decir 1 de cada 4 japoneses
tienen más de 65 años y cada hora que
pasa ojo la población del país desciende
en 50 personas
tal como lo escucháis de hecho el propio
gobierno de japón espera que la
población del país caiga por debajo de
los 100 millones de personas antes del
año 2050 y claro más ancianos menos
jóvenes y menos población pues tiene
consecuencias claras por un lado más
gasto público en pensiones o sanidad por
otro menos mano de obra
es verdad muchos otros países
desarrollados también tienen este
problema por ejemplo españa pero es que
el caso de japón es con diferencia el
mayor de todos y no lo es por casualidad
para nada
[Música]
por un lado amigos las empresas han
compensado todos los problemas que han
causado las malas políticas que hemos
visto en este vídeo obligando a sus
empleados a trabajar muchas más horas
que las que se trabajan en el resto de
países desarrollados lo que
evidentemente deja poco tiempo libre
para pensar en eso de formar una familia
por otro lado y lo vimos aquí también en
visual político mientras que algunos
países como por ejemplo alemania han
favorecido la llegada de muchos
inmigrantes que suelen tener tasas de
crecimiento demográfico más altas en
japón les han cerrado las puertas
de hecho cuando los organismos
internacionales le dicen a tokio que
tiene que abrir sus fronteras a la
inmigración para enfrentar el problema
del envejecimiento bueno desde el
gobierno japonés han llegado a decir
cosas como esta el ministro de finanzas
japonés pide a los ancianos que se den
prisa en morir en fin amigos
estas son fundamentalmente las causas
que han hecho que japón sea un país que
vive una especie de crisis continua y
también las causas que han hecho que el
modelo alemán haya claramente sido
superior al modelo japonés pero ahora
turno para ti
crees que japón logrará superar este
periodo de estancamiento y crisis
permanente déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
abisal político un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]